hierüber so jetzt sage ich hier ist aber
jetzt ein challenger-turnier mussten
chain partnern chain leggins oder change
estate
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
videospiel 9
und wir haben eine neue zuschauer
challenge die stammt von max riedl der
sagt du musst für jede kiste raten was
drinnen ist eine oder zwei sachen wenn
du richtig liegst darfst du mitnehmen
was in der kiste ist wenn du nicht
richtig liegst gar nichts dann muss ich
alles aus der kiste trend liegen lassen
kurz bevor es mit dem video weiter geht
eine kurze ansage von mir und zwar die
leute die mich schon ein bisschen länger
kennen wissen dass ich finde dass
youtube eine große reichweite haben auch
eine verpflichtung haben die reichweite
sinnvoll einzusetzen und ich habe
letztens überlegt okay was kannst du
machen
die kam erst unterstützte schon aber ich
wollte ein bisschen mehr machen und da
hat es sehr gut gepasst dass der wwf auf
mich zugegangen ist und gesagt hat wo
wir haben eine neue serie gestartet kann
man schaut geben und das mache ich gerne
das ganze ist natürlich unbezahlt also
ich dafür keinen cent ich sehe dafür
keine produkt oder sowas dass es
komplett
ich krieg dafür überhaupt nichts aber
ich mag das halt gern unterstützen das
projekt weil das in meinen augen sinn
macht und zwar eine serie gestartet er
ist pokal da sind ein paar richtig
witzige videos dabei den buckel der
glaube ich ein ehemaliger gamon
moderator ist ein bisschen erklärt
worauf man im alltag achten kann um die
umwelt zu schonen das ist einfach coole
sachen dabei nur darum werden rasierer
als käse opel verwendet boersego.de
alles klar gesteckt unbedingt mal die
playlist ab von dieser öko mit luke
serien á vis und verlinkt und falls
irgendwelche vorsätze für das jahr 2016
hat könnte die mal mit dem magic box
mein drucker mit dem hashtag bessere
vorsätze mal die kommentare schreiben
dass nämlich der hashtag dieser kampagne
und schreib mal rein ob die nach einem
monat überhaupt noch bestand haben würde
wie es bisher gelaufen ist okay das
war's soweit davon zurück zum video und
unverrichteter dinge weitergehen
das wollen wir natürlich überhaupt nicht
ist mega ärgerlich wenn man so eine
kiste vor sicher tollen items und man
darf nichts mitnehmen
deswegen müssen wir gut raten leute aber
man wird auch oft daneben legen wir
probieren unser glück ich sage in der
ersten küsse sind kekse oder äpfel kekse
oder äpfel und jawohl es sind äpfel und
damit dürfen die ganze kiste ausräumen
weil wir ein item richtig geraten haben
und schnell weiter bis zur nächsten
schnell schnell schnell schnell
die gegner warten nämlich nicht die
nutzen das aus meiner band und ich sage
in der kiste ist ein holzschwert oder in
gold wert und
nein ich hätte schwören können dass da
ein zu bleiben drin ist das war wie so
ein gefühl als wäre damit 100
prozentiger wahrscheinlichkeit was drin
aber man kann nie wissen das war der
beste beweis
deswegen ist es immer so ein bisschen
glück diese wahrsager challenge wir
müssen jetzt habe ich immer war sagen
was in den kisten drin ist gut ich
glaube hier ist jetzt aber ein
goldschmied oder eine gold drin gold
wert oder gold chat hauptsache gold ja
wohl die goldstadt ist am start sehr
schön gold enttäuscht mich nicht sehr
nice und sagt um gegen weiter pam pam
pam und jetzt hier aber jetzt braucht
pommern schwert leute oder welches modul
ist das 4 kommt jetzt darum 5 dann sage
ich es hier waren holz oder in
goldscheuer trend kommt schon lasst uns
nicht im stich das mich nicht im stich
nein aber okay es war rasch modul es war
damals module des streiks will auch
niemand haben ganz ehrlich niemand
wünscht eine excel glaube ich oder wollt
ihr stein extra ihr da draußen ich
glaube nicht oder
niemand wird stein extra deswegen
versuche ich ganz gerne mal hier dass
sie noch mitzunehmen mega knapp
angefühlt so lala schon wieder
das geht so bis in mein leben modul 5
sage ich jetzt kommt das erste stein
schwert oder ein change leggins oder
james blake
ich sagt leggins change agents oder
stein schwert go go go go go go go ja
wohl dass das stein schwert und ein helm
und dias madrid braucht man nicht sehr
schön und dann geht es weiter im text
wir sind auch gar nicht so schlecht
platziert glaube ich glaube wir sind
nicht ganz so platz eins weil er immer
so ein bisschen zeit an den kisten
verlieren aber wir stehen gut mal nicht
nervös sind eher gut passt jetzt sage
ich sowas könnte jetzt in der sein
changes plate oder change agents kommt
das will ich im stich und ist okay da
geht uns der enchanted durch die lappen
naja ich ärgerlich ärgerlich der
enchanted geht flöten
dass wir hier jetzt bisschen weiter nach
vorne kommen ja wohl
jawohl und checkpoint ja da ist das ding
sehr schön heißt noch mal versucht
nochmal ihr was richtig zu erraten
ich mache das immer so auf meine mit
wurde hier jackpot mitnehmen und dann
mit peer double jump dass sich immer
darüber so wie jetzt sage ich hier ist
aber jetzt in pattaya mussten chain
parteien chain leggins oder changes
petto
jawohl da ist das ding und eisen deckels
ist auch noch drin
jawoll so muss das sein sehr nice und da
kommt direkt dieses haben wir können
jetzt vielleicht punkten können jetzt
vielleicht punkten
drei tage später
jetzt haben wir sehr schön hier in die
kiste geschaut leute ok haben die kiste
geschaut dann müssen diese strafe
einfach dürfen zur strafe mal gar nichts
raus aus dieser kiste
wenn man nämlich voreilig in die kiste
schaut kann natürlich ein dass er nicht
mehr sagen ach ich glaube da war das und
was drin
dann muss man irgendwie bestraft werden
das heißt wir nehmen jetzt gar nichts
wird aus dieser kiste versuchen
stattdessen unser glück hier und ich
will jetzt ganz gerne mal eine eisen
schätzt oder ein entspannter das buch
haben und java ist die eisenbeiß
zuverlässig das ist sehr sehr
zuverlässig und dann machen wir jetzt
hier noch mal einen kleinen film start
raus wenn sie schon beim modul 10 dann
kümmert vielleicht sogar das gesamte
kino finnischen das wäre doch mal eine
sache
jetzt gas geben konzentrieren ist dabei
die sagen dass mich konzentrieren muss
keine miete nicht mehr konzentrieren wo
es ist ziemlich eng gerade drei mann
drei module 10 und wollen alle
finnischen ich und meine zwei gegner
aber wer wird schaffen wer behält die
konzentration bis zum ende
ich habe gesiegt die kamera darunter
fallen wenn man es nicht echt gebot das
will ich immer wissen
ok konzentrieren
aber wir sind wieder da müssen wir da so
ok und dann immer dass hier mit und
jetzt ist die kiste hier was kann hier
sei das kann dir sein zehntes buch oder
enchantment table eins von beidem und
und und und arm ist mein zu beiden dort
den bogen gebrauchen können ehrlich
gesagt so nehmen dass hier mit uns
natürlich ziehen und jawohl wir haben es
geschafft schönen findet rausgehauen
1 gg und geht death match beginnt in
stent alter so sagt wir dürfen die
rüstung hier anziehen und heute das war
knackig ich hab mich aus den händen auf
dem versuch gebraucht und meine kiste
aber wir haben jetzt leider keine angeln
das heißt wir müssen uns mit unserem
schwert moment und schwert skills bisher
durchboxen läuft ganz gut den ersten mal
schön gewollt so hier liegt eine
goldschmiede goldscheuer kommt auch müll
weg und hier kann man mal schön
abstauben kann sie ja wohl den hammer
dann schauen wir mal den dienst an der
gleichen stelle ja okay jetzt jetzt
jetzt beginnt wieder der held als sie
die abo träger des todes aber wenn
interna und geben den hohlen ja wohl und
habe wieder intelligenten sehr nahe so
muss das sein
immer schön taktisch kämpfen tadelt hier
achse die nächste runde war geraten der
runde hat die runde verlassen ist hier
ja wohl und schöne kleine schwert combo
aber ihr noch was drin ist kommt ja
wieder
olé olé olé olé weitere als ob beide
vorne wegrennen
das gibt's doch nicht das gibt es nicht
als ob ich okay das hat ja noch nie
das zweite gegner auf mich zu und ich
beide hätte und dann beide von mir
wecken das ist auch neu aber gut ich
habe erst mal den gold typen hier dürfte
das leichtere ziel sein
da haben wir ihn noch mal und ein hit
braucht noch dann haben ihn weg und da
haben wir eine schöne vision und
dahinter kommt schon der trainer
das wäre der fall wenn du oh gott oh
gott oh gott kommt gerda verdauen
er hat es überlebt wie zoll hat das
überlebt wir probieren einfach weiter
unser glück wir haben hier auch noch
einen tnt und in somborn aber wenn alles
schief läuft alles schief läuft haben
wir noch unser song we bring ach komm du
hast mich doch ein bisschen abstand habe
ich gefühlt dass über den spieß mal
umdrehen freuen uns über den kennen
spielt den spieß umdrehen und dich um
sterben nicht das wäre doch mal eine
schöne sache sagt zack zack zack zack
zack ihm hinterher
schön die treppen hoch mit letters
display und jetzt stadtmann zehner
hinter uns ist erst mal keiner sciences
läuft offenbar wie man zwischen uns
beiden ist schön den weg abschneiden wo
wieder lang da linksrum alles klar da
kommt ein bisschen abkürzen auf jeden
fall da geht es aber nicht lang da
geht's aber nicht lange wurde
und da gibt es auch nicht leider komme
ich damit zuvor und er kriegt noch an
mit gleichem weg gleichen weg gehen
wieder die ideallinie laufen und zack
zack zack zack da kriegt noch mal mit
der kann ich mir viele leben haben und
er hat nur noch 1 da hat man noch
einleben und viele herzen kann auch
nicht mehr abends heißt wenn wir jetzt
in seiner letzten herzen abziehen dann
fliegt er und er ist weg ja wohl schön
gucken was hat er hier den schalter kann
mit ein bisschen mut pangl ganz wichtig
unten bogen wir haben noch zwei leben
unser gegner noch einleben wird kein
killer rekord in dieser runde aber tue
mit der challenge nicht so easy probiert
die man zu hause aus ist nicht so easy
zu schließen falls nicht eintreffen so
isst du nicht nehmen in denen jetzt will
ich am schwerter das gibt sich neben den
nebra sagt kurths abstand halten und den
apfel essen immer gut für die gesundheit
dar wenn man die wände märkte gegner mit
den nahkampf gehen dessen vitamine sehr
wichtig und hier im ticker auch nicht
schaden leider läuft voll rein okay gibt
holland oder husten
zack zack zack zack zack zack zack
schöne schwert komme es völlig es weg
das ding gewonnen blogger gerade
eineinhalb stunden oder zwei stunden am
stück aufgenommen
aber wenn es geschafft heute sehr leicht
nach oben und weitere change vorschläge
in die kommentare
wir sind dann beim nächsten mal wieder
morgen opengl 3 watt genau diesem moment
ab dankeschön nicht so früh distanz
macht gut